jaison's with us in Athens Georgia hi
Jason how are you how's it going doing
where they appreciate taking my call
sure man what's up in your world I've
got a question on retirement I've got
kind of a different situation in that I
have a hereditary diseases called ataxia
and it's going to shorten my life
inspect to see a lot I'm 41 and I
roughly have about 10 years to go for
retirement age where I won't be able to
work and so I'm wondering should I be
putting more into my retirement right
now trying to store that up we've done
all our baby steps and paid off all our
dead except for a house and we just have
that left and I just want to know what's
the best way to save as much money as I
can so won't be a burden to to mama and
my daughter
what's your household income sir we are
at 80,000 your 86,000 you will you own
your home we owe 107 left on miles and
you're 41 yes and you estimate 10 years
yes sir okay um well here's the thing
you you have a pile of money and you
don't have a paid off mortgage or you
have a paid off mortgage and your pile
of money isn't as big right both are
things that add stability I mean the
pile of money or the paid off mortgage
both adds stability the those smaller
pile of money and the not or the not
paid off mortgage take away stability
right right right
but either one that you do obviously
doing both of them would be best but
either one that you do causes your
family to be more stabilized to take
care of them as you're seeing any and
you know to prepare for retirement so um
I think what this does is it increases
the the the focus and the intensity with
every dollar that you make but I still
think I want my house paid off by that
time that's a say that
because I didn't want that to be a
burden in any way in the next 10 years
for them I think within a ghazal
intensity we can get it paid off in the
next six years by by throwing a little
extra at the pumps for each Monday with
a lot of time yeah but I think you need
to do the 15% and that way you're going
to have because you know that way you're
going to have a pretty good liquid nest
egg to have you got life insurance on
you already yes sir yes I did all that
before I had to go get the test and
stuff uncle was an insurance agent back
in the day and so he he said it's a
great on that stuff everything I keep
all that keep all of that in place how
much coverage of you got I've got right
at 99,000 in life insurance and turn so
I did I wish I'd listened to you before
we do have some whole life so I got to
try to you try to change that over now
sure don't be changing that you're
probably not insurable yes and that's
true that's true
you might be pre-existing station you
might be but I don't know with what
you're describing a shortened life span
you know would definitely affect life
insurance without a doubt so I think the
normal baby steps is probably still best
but certainly you know I'm going to put
15 percent away towards retirement but
I'm going to really lean on that house
and say like you said six years seven
years eight years have that dude knocked
out while I'm doing that 15 percent it's
probably going to mean you don't do some
other stuff but those two goals both of
those goals are really really important
in preparing for the storm which is what
you're doing right that's correct yeah
you're good man sir thank you for
thinking about your family the way you
are and thinking about yourself in a
responsible way it's an honor to talk to
you and anymore anything I can do to
help you anytime you call me back
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
free
think you've lost your mind